خلوني ارجع بحياتي سنتين انسان حياته
مالهاش لازمه ما كنتش عارف هو ايه هدفي
بالظبط كان طول الوقت نفسي ان اهلي يعوني
كاني بني ادم كبير بس المعامله دي انا ما
كنتش استحقها كنت طول الوقت اروح اكلم امي
تعملني كاني لسه طفل صغير كل مره ابص في
عيون ابويا احس ان عمره ما هيقدر يعتمد
عليا طب مش مهم اهلي دلوقتي خروجاتي مع
اصحابي كان ليها سبب واحد بس اللي انا
بدور على نفسي في عيونهم مره كوره مره
سباحه مره سكواش مره تنس كان كل دول ابواب
بشهم بس عشان اطلع من الناحيه التانيه
وتبقى كل مره فتره تانيه من حياتي ضاعت
بدون
لازمه في 2009
رحت
معحب مش مهم انت ممكن تبقى احسن في حاجه
تانيه لحد مارس
2012 رحله مع المدرسه زي اي رحله قبل كده
بس عشان الجات ه الرحله دي اتغير تماما مع
اول مره نزلت فيها تحت
الميه الكلمه اللي بتسمعها بتاعك عشان
تسيب وراك دنيا مليانه مشاكل وحق وتكبر
لدنيا المعنى الوحيد
فيها لدنيا كل واحد فيها محتاج التاني
عشان يعيش كل واحد فيها ل لاز من اول
الشخاف منه
لحدك عليها لشوف في
التلفزيون
تحت الميه او في الرحله دي انا حسيت بشعور
عم ما كنت حسيته قبل كده احساس العده وانا
بلبسها احساس الماسك ما بيخليش ابص ولا
يمين ولا شمال بس ببص قدامي بس احساس ان
انا مش سامع اي حد ولا اي حاجه غ صوت
هوايا انا تحت الميه انا كنت ملك نفسي تحت
الميه ماكانش في حد بيتحكم فيا او بيحكم
علي على اساس الدرجات اللي انا بجيبها على
اساس انا بعرف العب كوره ولا لا تحت الميه
الوحيد اللي كان بيتحكم فيا كان هو انا
عدى اول وتاني وثالث ورابع وخامس يوم
وللاسف جه الوقت اللي لازم نرجع فيه تاني
القاهره جه الوقت اللي الباب اتفتح لي
ابتدى يتقفل مره تانيه حياتي اللي كنت طول
الوقت بحاول اهرب منها ابتدت ترجع لي تاني
واحده واحده و لحد اقدمت عدت بقيه السنه
ما خلصتش فيها ولا مره وج الصيف وعد الصيف
وبرضو ما خصش ولا مره لحد ما تقدمت لنا
فكره الكس اللي هي طبعا عظمتنا كلنا في
الحياه كريتيفيتي اللي هي اصلا مش موجوده
عندي اكشن كنت انسان انتوخ بيقعد بس في
بيته عشان ياكل ويشرب وسيرس اللي كنت
بعملها بس عشان اش
الوقتي سالت نفسي اعمل ايه السؤال ده انا
بساله نفسي كل فتره عشان اتاكد انا مين
انا ايه هو هدفي بالظبط وانا رايح على فين
بسبب السؤال ده انضميت لي مجموعه اسمها اي
دايف
تراي مجموعه افتخر اني اقول اللي انا فرض
فيها مجموعه غيرت هدف الغطس بالنسبه لي
تماما الغطس بالنسبه لنا ما بقتش هوايه بس
بس بقى واجب علينا والبحر بالنسبه لنا بقى
هو بيتنا
التاني مع المجموعه دي او بسبب الغص انا
بقيت انسان تاني تمام انسان واثق في نفسه
في تعامله مع الناس انسان لقى الحاجه اللي
بتميزه انسان لما بيبص في عيون امه وابوه
بيحس ان هم فخورين بيه بس الاهم من ده كله
انسان لقى معنى السعاده في
الحياه بعد ما انضميت للمجموعه دي قريت
كتاب كان قد كده طبعا كان اول واخر كتاب
اقرا في
حياتي كتاب اسمه الفنت وسبر بيتكلم على
راجل بينقذ الفقره عشان بسببنا احنا البني
ادمين
حياه اصحاب الارض بقت في ازمه طبعا في فرق
كبير قوي ما بين الفيل والسمكه بس كانت
السمكه هي الحاجه اللي انا اقدر انفذها
سلاحي
سلاحف سلاحف ب هو الاسم اللي انا معروف
بيه دلوقتي في وسط اصحابي ده لما انضميت
لبروجكت تبع هدفه ان ننقذ السلاحف من
الانقراض في الاول انا كنت فاكرها تريقه
بس ما همنيش اي حاجه من الكلام ده عشان مع
كل سلحفه كنت بشفها بترجع اليه كنت بحس
بسعاده غير
طبيعيه السلحفه هي حاجه بسيطه في وسط بيئه
كبيره قوي خلوني اقوللكم سال كنت سمعته
قبل كده اذا كنت تظن حقا ان البيئه اقل
اهميه من
الاقتصاد فجرب ان تعد اموالك بدون ان
تتنفس خلوني اشرحلكم
الك في الانسان اللي معاه فلوس كتيره قوي
وفي الولد
ص وفي الولد اللي بجيب درجات عاليه قوي كل
الناس بتطلب من مساعده بس ازي هيعيش لو
مفيش اصلا لوفي الاكسجين في اله انت
عارفين 7 في من الاسين دلوقتي
حالنا اصلا من
البح انت عارفين الميه هي اهم حاجه في
حياه النبات والحيوان
والانسان طب برضو مش مهم الحاجات دي زي ما
قلت لكم قبل كده البحر بالنسبه للغطاسين
هو بيتهم التاني فتخيلوا الواحد بيحس بايه
مع كل حاجه بيشوفها مرميه تحت بيته
بيشوفها مرميه في بيته تخيلوا احنا كغطاء
حاجه بنشوفها مرميه تحت الميه سواء كانت
كان او كيس او علبه سجاير او السيجاره
نفسها كل واحد في كل واحد فينا عنده
الحاجه اللي بتميزه كل واحد فينا عنده
الحاجه اللي هيفيد بيها المجتمع وبيفيد
بيها الناس انا لقيت الحاجه دي انا لقيت
الغطس الغطس بالنسبه لي بقى هو معنى
سعادتي في الحياه والبحر بالنسبه لي بقى
هو بيتي التاني عشان كده انا عندي ليكم
طلب واحد بس النهارده بك
اوشك
شكرا
ه